my name is Ben Lyons I'm hosting Holly
shorts opening night tonight and I'm a
producer on alakazoom how did that film
come to me how did you get involved and
what is he's about sell it was like a
big brother to me when I worked at the e
channel and when I found out that he his
buddy Jason Berg were putting this story
together about his life but his music
and his dad I said I got to be a part of
it somehow someway and came into the
process and I really just really enjoyed
being on the other side of it you know
for me someone who watches some reviews
movies to work on making a movie and
then rolling it out at all these
different festivals you went to Tribeca
earlier this year and now to share it
here in the famed chinese theatre
supreme culture i'm so thrilled how is
it you know delving into someone's life
like that because it's a very personal
story it's a very emotional story for
Sal we're really lucky that we had a
subject like Sal Masekela because
anybody who knows how he's the same on
TV as he is in person if he's with
somebody's note for 20 years or a fan on
the street he's the same guy so
he was going to go on this journey and
expose a new side of himself playing
music we all know and love him on the X
Games but this is some different for him
and it was a scary experience but if
anyone was brave enough to go through to
a south so we just tagged along for the
ride right what do you think it is about
a father-son story that just touches at
people's heart strings I mean why is it
so emotional for people well we all have
you know a relationship with our Father
either we know them and are close to
them or we never met them but there's
still a relationship in that way there
and force Alan his dad they've been
through so many highs and lows and its
really interesting when you have two
people father and son were both in the
public eye and are presenting different
sides of themselves and what we see on
TV or listen to you know in their music
so I think in this particular case to
have a father-son story where you have
no elements of their journey but to see
new sides of that experience is what
makes it a special if everything did
anyone give you feedback as far as when
they saw it at Tribeca yeah you know
like wow that really changed my view of
my father or yeah my father my dad came
to our premier Tribeca and he endowed
Sal from coming by the e-channel over
the years and unknown south sad music
but he said wow I look at them in a
different light now and I looked at you
as my son in a different light so it's
really nice to share that this
father-son story with my dad too
and lastly what do you think people will
take away from the film like what do you
want them to gain from it or you just
want them to see you sort of as a
portrait of someone's life I think okay
well people can ultimately take away
from our film is that it shouldn't be
afraid of reinvention and when you
challenge yourself to do something
different you kind of return to who you
really are and for Sal you know somebody
made a name for himself on in the world
of action sports and on TV to go into
this career as a musician it was a way
for him to find himself and kind of
complete the journey for him so I would
say anybody watching this don't be
afraid to try something completely
different because you might found out
found find out who you really are very
nice yeah right excited to see it thanks
so much